streit um hilfe für die kommunen
bundesfinanzminister scholz plant einen
rettungsschirm er soll 57 milliarden
euro betragen
trauriger rekord in russland 119 corona
tote an einem tag viele kliniken sind
überlastet nach der zwangspause
der ball rollt wieder in der fußball
bundesliga allerdings unter strengen
auflagen
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
petra gerster guten abend und willkommen
zu unserem nachrichtenüberblick an
diesem samstag die korona krise hat die
finanzielle situation vieler städte und
gemeinden dramatisch verschlechtert
einnahmen brechen weg dafür werden neue
verpflichtungen fällig jetzt will
finanzminister scholz helfen
fast 57 milliarden sollen für einen
rettungsschirm bereit gestellt werden
die last sollen sich der bund und die
jeweils verantwortlichen länder teilen
und schon gibt es neuen streit in der
koalition florian hand berichtet die
ausflugsschiffe in schwerin bleiben auch
heute am steg keine einnahmen und damit
auch keine steuern für die stadt ein
viertel der gewerbesteuer bricht dem
schwerin der oberbürgermeister in diesen
tagen wird das macht für unseren
haushalt etwas mehr als 20 millionen
euro pro jahr also in diesem jahr - wir
mussten für jeden euro zweimal umdrehen
das müssen wir jetzt natürlich noch mal
mehr was tun 200 km entfernt präsentiert
der finanzminister heute seine antwort
in der berliner spd parteizentrale
stellt er den kommunen milliarden hilfen
in aussicht wir müssen dafür sorgen dass
die einnahmeausfälle die in diesem jahr
entstehen nicht dazu führen dass
investitionen zurückgefahren werden
scholz vorschlag sieht zweierlei vor
einerseits eine akute nothilfe darüber
hinaus eine entlastung bei den
kommunalen altschulden die gesamtkosten
von fast 57 milliarden euro sollen zur
hälfte von den ländern zur anderen
hälfte vom bund getragen werden
bei der aber nicht für kommunale
finanzen zuständig ist muss dafür erst
einmal das grundgesetz geändert werden
die linke im bundestag kündigt schon mal
zustimmung an
ich kann jetzt nur sagen der vorschlag
ist richtig aber es gibt hier sehr viel
gegenwehr aus der union herr scholz muss
sich jetzt gegen die union durchsetzen
tatsächlich führt die sich vom vorschlag
aus dem willy-brandt-haus brüskiert
schimpft über parteitaktik und über ein
konzept von gestern
das heute nicht mehr zu finanzieren sei
olaf scholz glaube ich sollte bevor er
solche milliardenschweren programme in
die welt hinausposaunt sich darüber im
klaren sein was kostet die krise noch
sparen sei die falsche antwort in dieser
krise heißt es in schwerin das würde die
probleme nur verschärfen also braucht
man hilfe geld woher das kommt ist dabei
vermutlich egal
nach dem rauswurf des brandenburgischen
vorsitzenden kalbitz aus der afg
zeichnet sich ein machtkampf ab der
thüringer fraktionschef ecke sagte er
werde die spaltung und zerstörung der
partei nicht zulassen
dem fdp-vorsitzenden meuten und
parteivize von storch warf er verrat an
der partei vor der bundesvorstand der
afg hatte gestern die mitgliedschaft von
kalbitz für nichtig erklärt das original
seines aufnahmeantrags könne die afg
allerdings nicht mehr auffinden
berichtet die faz
kalbitz wird vorgeworfen bei seinem
eintritt in die partei die
mitgliedschaft in einer rechtsextremen
organisation verheimlicht zu haben
eine auswirkung der korona krise war das
schließen der europäischen grenzen hart
vor allem für die die sonst täglich hin
und her pendeln zwischen den
nachbarländern
es schien als habe das virus den
europäischen gedanken kurzfristig
ausgelöscht als sei die idee von
schengen tod oder zumindest vergessen
heute hat man versucht sie wieder zum
leben zu erwecken und die
deutsch-luxemburgische grenze geöffnet
andreas künast war dabei
bevor deutschland das erste stück grenze
aufmacht ist die körpertemperatur des
außenministers wichtig und die aller
mitreisenden auch ohne abstimmung ohne
aufsehen und ohne minister waren die
grenzen geschlossen worden
zur eröffnung reist heiko maas nach
luxemburg der erste regierungsflugzeug
zehn wochen virus pause es soll
symbolisch werden in schengen auf der
moselbrücke geben sich die zwei
außenminister nicht die hand jean
asselborn freut sich höflich obwohl es
luxemburg sehr verärgert hat dass
deutschland die grenze einseitig sperrte
das war nicht gut
[Musik]
schengen am leben halten und ein meter
fünfzig abstand die gesten europäischer
eintracht sind schwierig geworden für
mars sind geschlossene grenzen und
europäisch zum teil aber auch notwendig
war jeder erstmal selber dafür sorgen
muss dass die situation in seinem land
unter kontrolle hat denn das ist die
voraussetzung dafür dass man auch
anderen helfen kann
seit mitternacht ist deutschland wieder
geöffnet zumindest von luxemburg aus
ab montag will maas mit zehn weiteren
ländern verhandeln
der tag in schengen soll das auftakt-
signal sein ob der geist von schengen
die korona krise überleben wird ist
alles andere als sicher
denn erinnern wird man sich wohl kaum an
die wiedereröffnung der grenzen sondern
vor allem daran wie schnell und panisch
und ohne absprache sie geschlossen
wurden
anderswo sind die lockerungen noch
eingeschränkt und es wird noch ein paar
wochen dauern bis der reiseverkehr
auch an anderen binnen europäischen
grenzen wieder wie früher rollen kann
aber im juni könnte es dann soweit sein
rechtzeitig vor den sommerferien wie es
bis dahin an den grenzen zu frankreich
der schweiz und österreich aussieht
schildert julia schröter die
freundschafts brücke in
kleinblittersdorf im saarland auf der
einen seite deutschland auf der anderen
frankreich ab heute ist es auch hier
leicht
über die grenze zu kommen für viele
bürger die ganz eng sind mit ihren
nachbarn eine gute nachricht
das ist ja das schöne dass es eigentlich
hier ein wechsel gibt an der
freundschafts brücke dieses hin und her
das ist schon einiges kaputtgegangen
weil die franzosen meine frau durfte
nicht rüber sie ist zwei monate zu hause
geblieben der weg über die grenze auf
der brücke scheint er ganz unkompliziert
doch es gelten weiterhin klare wenn auch
gelockerte regeln und zwar nicht nur an
den übergängen nach frankreich sondern
auch zur schweiz und nach österreich
wieder erlaubt ist die einreise in beide
richtungen um den lebenspartner oder
verwandte zu besuchen
für hochzeiten oder andere anlässe darf
man ebenfalls über die grenze und auch
immobilien und grundstücksbesitzer
dürfen wieder einreißen weiter verboten
bleiben fahrten aus touristischen
gründen zum einkaufen und zum tanken wer
war einer der jetzt nur noch
stichprobenartig durchgeführten
kontrollen gestoppt wird muss eine
selbsterklärung vorzeigen und angeben
warum er unterwegs ist bei missachtung
drohen strafen
das formular kann jeder auf der
internetseite der bundespolizei
herunterladen
mitte juni sollen die beschränkungen
dann ganz wegfallen
das macht auch den gastwirten und
hoteliers mut die jetzt wenigstens auf
eine gute sommersaison hoffen
davon möchte auch italien profitieren
die regierung in rom hat entschieden ab
dem dritten juni seine grenzen zu öffnen
damit ist auch italien ein mögliches
ziel für den sommerurlaub
schauen wir an dieser stelle auf die
aktuellen zahlen zur pandemie in
deutschland sachsen-anhalt meldet heute
erstmals keinen einzigen neuen fall auch
bundesweit gehen die neuinfektionen im
durchschnitt der letzten sieben tage
weiter zurück auf inzwischen 660
ansteckungen täglich insgesamt sind mehr
als 175.000 infektionen durch tests
bestätigt davon gelten fast 152000
betroffene als genießen 7931 menschen
sind in verbindung mit cupid 19
gestorben
im kreis heinsberg ist es zu einem
weiteren massiven corona ausbruch
gekommen
der paketzusteller dpd er hat einen
standort vorübergehen
geschlossen 80 von 400 beschäftigten
wurden positiv getestet
die behörden suchen nun nach weiteren
kontaktpersonen in dem kreis in
nordrhein westfalen war es bereits im
februar zu einem der ersten großen
ausbrüche des bewohner virus in
deutschland gekommen
immer mehr corona maßnahmen werden
gelockert
dennoch gab es heute wieder vielerorts
demonstrationen gegen die beschränkungen
wieder mit dabei
verschwörungstheoretiker aber vor allem
wohl auch menschen die sich in ihren
freiheiten beschnitten fühlen
die politik reagiert zum teil mit
verständnis waren dabei auch davor dass
extremisten die die demonstrationen
unterwandert
andreas linke und sandra susanka die
größte demonstration war wieder in
stuttgart auf dem festgelände am
cannstatter wasen 5000 teilnehmer hatte
die stadt zugelassen
die veranstalter wollten die 10 fache
zahl anmelden der widerstand gegen die
korona maßnahmen ein die demonstranten
vielen war aber auch die abgrenzung zu
extremisten wichtig wie nazi neonazis
aussehen und ich muss feststellen die
haben sich ja alle verkleidet die sehen
ja alle aus wie normale bürger ja ich
wollte mir hier mal selbst ein bild
verschaffen weil wenn ich so die medien
mir anschaue dann geht ja gesagt also da
sind rechtsradikale darum link
verschwörungstheoretiker und ein paar
normale bürger sind auch dabei
audi stellt fest das sind sehr sehr
viele ganz normale bürger zu denen ich
mich auch zähle
für den soziologen amina sie liegt es
auch bei der politik ihre ziele und
maßnahmen noch besser verständlich zu
machen
die angemessene reaktion ist glaube ich
die ziele der maßnahmen die wir im
moment haben klar zu kommunizieren das
heißt zu sehen dass öffnungen und ein
monitoring dieser öffnungen tatsächlich
plausibel erklärt werden muss
1000 teilnehmer durften auf die
theresienwiese in münchen sie hielten
sich in stuttgart an die abstandsgebot
hätte ich kann die maßnahme stand
verstehen aber ich persönlich finde ich
schon zu greifen genauso wie das mit dem
mundschutz auch ich denke das hat alle
seine psychologischen hintergrund und
man will uns eigentlich nur mundtot
machen ränge gab es allerdings am rande
der theresienwiese
hier griff schließlich die polizei hat
am rande einer kundgebung in halle ist
ein team des zdf bei dreharbeiten von
demonstranten bedrängt worden
nach verbalen attacken ging die polizei
dazwischen um eine weitere eskalation zu
verhindern
verletzt wurde niemand die proteste
hatten gegner der korona maßnahmen aus
dem rechten spektrum organisiert nach
russland weltweit hat das land die
zweithöchsten infektionszahlen heute gab
es mit 119 die höchste zahl an toten
innerhalb eines tages
laut johns hopkins universität sind mehr
als 200 72.000 infektionen durch tests
bestätigt die lage in russischen
kliniken ist sehr unterschiedlich immer
wieder klagen ärzte ist fehle an
personal und schutzausrüstung in eine
moskauer corona klinik konnte sich unser
reporter christian selber schauen erst
mal runter in den keller
die katakomben von krankenhaus 52
bislang wurden unsere drei anfragen für
ein krankenhaus immer abgelehnt jetzt
dürfen wir rein an schutzausrüstung wie
in manch anderer russischer klinik
mangelt es hier nicht
vorbereitet dass wir auf die station
gehen würden vor corona war das hier ein
normales krankenhaus jetzt alles
umgestellt auf cupid 19
die gänge leer die zimmer aber voll 900
betten 750 sind belegt und es wird noch
angebaut zusatz betten für alle fälle
fachärzte nun ärzte wurden umgeschult um
corona patienten zu behandeln
moskau war von anfang an besser
vorbereitet auf diese situation auch
technisch und vom personal her
ich glaube dass es die kollegen
außerhalb moskaus schwerer haben gelinde
gesagt das ist die rote zone die
intensivstation ist voll die meisten
patienten müssen beatmet werden zwar
gebe es im chor ohne hotspot moskau
immer mehr infizierte aber die zahl der
patienten bleibe stabil
sagen sie hier im zimmer nebenan bringt
ein mann gerade mit dem tod
der druck auf uns ist viel höher als
sonst wir verbringen hier dreimal mehr
zeit als normal arbeiten jeden tag zwölf
stunden
es ist also sehr schwierig wir haben
hier engagierte ärzte pfleger und
freiwillige getroffen die genau wissen
dass die arbeitsbedingungen hier besser
sind als in anderen krankenhäusern
doch wenn die zahl der patienten steigt
sind sie auch hier schnell am limit
motivation kommt von den nachbarn
dort steht unsere ärzte sind helden
das klavier ist bestimmt weiterhin unser
nachrichtengeschehen bezüglich aktueller
entwicklungen sind sie online mit
unserer zdf heute app jederzeit auf dem
laufenden
in unserem live blog die fußballlose
zeit hat ein ende
gut zwei monate nach dem corona stopp
rollt der ball wieder in der bundesliga
doch an dieses bild müssen wir uns erst
noch gewöhnen lehre zuschauertribünen
die fans müssen draußen bleiben fünf
begegnungen stehen heute auf dem
programm darunter auch das revier derby
zwischen dortmund und schalke
thomas münten über die stimmung der fans
es ist 15 30 und wir haben an die
biografie
das beginnt gleich das klingt die miete
grund die natur hat im dortmunder
stadion turnhallen atmosphäre auf
schalke sogar noch weniger
gelsenkirchen heute nachmittag alle fan
knappen geschlossen
in der city mäßiger betrieb aber niemand
im trikot spuren des revierderbys muss
man lange suchen
in der kleingartenanlage trienen wald
scared maibaum zumindest mal die
schalker flagge
er hatte karten für das spiel und jetzt
will er gar nichts mehr davon hören
das darf nicht gemacht werden aber die
dürfen fußballspielen das passt alles
nicht zusammen
finde ich gute und friedhelm neumann
sehen das anders das revierderby aber
auch familiensache wir brauchen ein
bisschen mehr ist rund um das dortmunder
stadion schon los mit journalisten mehr
polizisten mehr ordner mehr absperrung
nur fußballfans auch hier fehlanzeige
claudia kommt trikot auf dem fahrrad
vorbei das ist einfach krass und ich
finde auch in dortmund sind heute die
straßen richtig leer
es ist ein ziemlich trauriges derby
natürlich dass mein 58 das heute ist
natürlich für alle den fußball ganz
trauriger tag hier
eines war das aber heute auch das
friedlichste revierderby seit gründung
der bundesliga ohne fans in den stadien
fielen also heute die tore in der
fußball-bundesliga nach 63 tagen
zwangspause kam so auch wieder bewegung
in die tabelle
marc windgassen fasst die zahlen des 26
spieltages für uns zusammen und so
lauten die ergebnisse düsseldorf trennt
sich vom paderborn 0 zu 0 dann dortmund
gewinnt gegen schalke klar mit 4 0 der
höchste derby-sieg übrigens seit 1966
für den bvb augsburg gegen wolfsburg 1 2
in hoffenheim unter liegt berlin mit 0 3
und leipzig mit nur einem punkt gegen
freiburg in die partie frankfurt gegen
gladbach läuft gerade alle anderen
spiele dann morgen bzw
am montag der blick auf die tabelle
bayern münchen weiter an der spitze nur
noch einen punkt vor den bvb aber auch
mit einem spiel weniger
gladbach kann leipzig heute abend über
holen da spielt exklusiv im aktuellen
sportstudio in der unteren
tabellenhälfte alles beim alten am
tabellenende wollte der sc paderborn
düsseldorf rangiert auf dem wichtigen
relegationsplatz markus harm ist in
frankfurt vor der commerzbank-arena für
uns da läuft gerade das
samstagabendspiel eintracht frankfurt
gegen borussia mönchengladbach
markus wie lief denn heute der erste
geisterspiel tag so ganz allgemein
ja es läuft wird der fußball mit
zweikämpfen mit toren mit emotionen nur
eben ohne zuschauer und der erste
sogenannte geisterspiel tag nach
neuneinhalb wochen fußballlose zeit
verläuft besser als wohl alle kritiker
angenommen haben keine ansammlung von
fans vor den stadien gute spiele schöne
tore und ein klares hygiene konzept an
das sich fast alle halten
auch hier in frankfurt nur hertha bsc
hat bei allen drei toren in einer
jubeltraube gefeiert das eigentlich
verboten ansonsten die neue normalität
der bundesliga sozusagen zieht die
weltweite aufmerksamkeit auf sich ob in
england den usa oder in asien überall
wurden die spiele live gezeigt und die
liga hat bewiesen es geht zwar ohne fans
aber immerhin wie der fussball
vielen dank markus haben zum schluss
widmen wir uns am heutigen 16
mai dem tag des lichts so hat es die
unesco bestimmt und seiner bedeutung für
wissenschaft und kultur im italienischen
brixen hat ein künstler den
internationalen tag des lichts mit einer
besonderen aktion gefeiert mit seenot
fackeln hüllte er den domplatz in roten
schein kilometerweit strahlte das licht
ins südtiroler umland vielleicht ein
zeichen der hoffnung in der korona zeit
zumindest aber ein schöner anblick den
bietet auch das wetter am sonntag da
scheint vor allem in der mitte die sonne
die details erfahren sie gleich von
özden terli danke für ihr interesse an
diesen nachrichten gegen 22.45 meldet
sich dann marietta slomka mit dem heute
journal
wir verabschieden uns wünschen ein
entspanntes wochenende und sind morgen
wieder für sie da
[Musik]
einen schönen guten abend und herzlich
willkommen zum wetter in der kühlen luft
im norden haben sich heute etliche
quellwolken gebildet sehen es hier
gleich die weißen gepunkteten flächen
hier quasi die wie popcorn in die höhe
schießen und da gab es einzelne schauer
viel war es nicht mehr regen gab es
heute im süden hier aus der schicht
bewölkung dazwischen war es ziemlich
sonnig mit kaum bewölkung ja und in der
nacht regnet es etwas an der nordsee und
richtung oder und neiße
dazu weht der wind kräftig aus
westlichen richtungen nach süden hin ist
es eher trocken und stern klar bei
temperaturen um null grad in der eifel
und 8 grad zum beispiel richtung berlin
brandenburg oder an der nordsee morgen
im tagesverlauf wieder im norden
dichtere bewölkung oder kann es regnen
und zwar von der ostsee in richtung
nordsee hier im binnenland und dazu ist
der wind kräftig aus westlichen
richtungen
südlich des mains gibt es sehr viel
sonnenschein und hier ist kaum eine
wolke unterwegs und das bei temperaturen
von bis zu 22 grad im südwesten und 14
grad in schleswig-holstein das ist quasi
die temperaturspanne und die nächsten
tage am montag im norden regen sonst im
süden sonniger bis 24 grad und ab
dienstag sommerlich warm um 25 grad
ein schöner abend